A scary grandmother figure doling out advice
and punishment feels like a familiar monster
to a lot of us.
Which could be why today’s monster originally
from Russian and East Slavic folklore feels
so ubiquitous.
She’s been the subject of operas, comic
book storylines, children’s books and cartoons,
and her own films—not to mention hundreds
of years of folklore history.
May I present, Baba Yaga.
Today, she is most commonly depicted as an
ugly, evil witch—but that wasn’t always
her story.
Baba Yaga was once more goddess than witch,
who reigned over time, life, death, and the
elements.
She was associated with strong winds and dark
forests, connected to the earth, the heavens,
and the underworld.
She straddles the boundary between life and
death.
So which witch is it?
Elemental goddess?
Dark sorceress?
Terrifying granny?
Let’s find out!
[Monstrum intro.]
Associated with powerful magic and accused
of cannibalism, she has immense powers over
animals, the elements, and even time.
Not all stories explicitly depict Baba Yaga
as an ugly witch—but most Russians would.
She is portrayed as a tall, gaunt old woman:
many tales reference her “bony leg,” which
might be severe thinness, or it might be a
literal skeleton leg.
She has disheveled hair and a sometimes iron
nose that is so long she can lie down on the
floor of her hut and it could touch the ceiling.
That large nose allows her to identify her
visitors by scent, leading some folklorists
to argue that she’s actually blind.
The powerful Yaga always lives somewhere remote,
usually in a deep forest.
Her home, while occasionally a grand mansion,
is most often a hut supported by chicken legs,
goat legs, ram horns, or spindles, and is
surrounded by a fence made from human bones
with the lock on her gate made from the sharp
teeth of a human jaw—so you can see why
people think she might be a cannibal.
The hut is constantly spinning, and will only
stop with the chant: “Little house, little
house.
Turn your back to the forest, your front to
me.”
Baba Yaga’s possessions are just as mystical—and
complex.
No flying broom for this witch: the Baba Yaga
travels on a magical flying mortar, using
a pestle to urge it on, sweeping away the
path of her flight... with a broom.
She owns enchanted mirrors that turn into
lakes, combs that can transform into forests,
handkerchiefs that become rivers, a flying
carpet, and fire-breathing horses.
Based on the etymology of her name, Baba Yaga
probably dates back to at least the Medieval
period.
And there are literally thousands of Baba
Yaga stories in Russian and Slavic folklore.
The first documented evidence of Baba emerges
in woodblock prints from the late 17th century
and early 18th century indicating she was
a known figure in their early oral traditions.
The first written mention of the Baba Yaga
is in the 1755 notes of a Russian grammar
book penned by poet and scientist Mikhail
[Mi-kha-il] V. Lomonosov [Luh-muh-noh-suf];
he referred to ‘Iaga Bab’a twice, including
in a list comparing Roman gods with their
Slavic and Russian correspondents—although
she is given no counterpart.
The first narrative account of the Baba Yaga
is in Vasilii Levshin’s 1780 collection
Russian Fairy Tales, in which she is depicted
as terrifying and dangerous, with teeth like
tusks and hands like bear claws.
Until the 19th century, Baba Yaga was a largely
Eastern European monster, but she gained international
recognition when translations of Aleksandr Afanasyev’s
1855-1863 serial publications of 600 transcribed
Russian folktales appeared in the 1870s.
His collection was styled like that of the
famed Brothers Grimm, though the inclusion
of his sources and the places where he heard
the stories lends greater scholarly legitimacy
to his work.
Later, a Russian illustrator used this collection to create some of the
most famous renderings of Russian folk characters—including
this one of the Baba Yaga in 1899.
She can be altruistic, giving the protagonist
of the story gifts or advice.
And even in the scariest stories, when she’s
a child kidnapper, a warrior witch, or a cruel
trickster, the protagonist always escapes,
and despite her iron teeth and associations
with cannibalism, no one in Baba Yaga stories
is ever eaten.
Many Baba Yaga stories feature a young protagonist
just entering into adulthood or marriage.
In one such story, a father gives his daughter
to Baba Yaga as a servant.
The daughter completes her assigned chores
perfectly, with the help of little mice.
Impressed by her work, Baba Yaga rewards the
girl with beautiful clothing.
When the father checks to see if his daughter
is alive, he is surprised to find her “very
rich.”
He takes her home, but her stepmother (of
course there’s an evil stepmother) is jealous,
so she sends her own daughter to Baba Yaga—but
this girl chases the mice with a rolling pin
and doesn’t do any of the work required
of her so Baba Yaga breaks her into pieces
and puts her bones in a box.
Not exactly evil, not quite benevolent there
Baba Yaga.
Then there’s one of the most beloved of
Russian folktales--“Vasilisa the Beautiful.”
On her deathbed, a merchant’s wife gives
a doll to their only daughter,Vasilisa, telling
her that she must always keep the doll with
her.
If anything bad should happen to the girl,
she is to give the doll food and ask its advice,
and the doll will help her.
Eventually, Vasilisa’s father remarries
a widowed woman with daughters of her own;
and just like in the story of Cinderella,
Vasilisa’s new stepmother and sisters are
far from kind, jealous of her goodness and
her beauty.
They do all they can to diminish her allure
with hard physical work.
To their dismay, Vasilisa grows healthier
and more lovely, while the evil women grow
uglier from their spite.
But how does the girl flourish despite their
cruel actions?
The doll.
Every night Vasilisa secretly feeds the dolls
and asks its advice.
The doll comforts her and speaks wise words—and
the next day it does all of the girl’s work
for her.
When it is time for Vasilisa to marry, all
the bachelors pine for her hand, and the jealous
stepmother grows even more enraged.
She moves them all to a new home near the
dense forest where Baba Yaga lives.
One night, Vasilisa and her stepsisters are
working by candlelight when a stepsister purposefully
snuffs out the light
, and then instructs Vasilisa to go
to Baba Yaga’s hut for a new flame.
Scared of being eaten by Baba Yaga, Vasilisa
consults her doll.
The doll’s eyes glow and it says that as
long as it is with her, she will be safe.
So Vasilisa sets off for Baba Yaga’s hut.
Once in the woods, she is approached in turns
by three horsemen: first, a man dressed in
white atop a white steed and accompanied by
daybreak; next, a man in red riding a red
horse blls that still have their eyes.
At that moment, a man clad in black, with
an ebony stallion seeminehind whom the sun
rises.Vasilisa approaches a fence made of
human bones topped with skug to beckon the
oncoming night sky disappears at Baba Yaga’s
gate made of men’s legs.
The bolts are arms, and the lock is a mouth
with sharp teeth.
The eyes in the skulls begin to shine, lighting
the clearing as if it were day.
She has arrived at Baba Yaga’s hut.
Suddenly there is a horrible roar and the
terrifying woman bursts out of the forest
[riding in her mortar].
Bravely, Vasilisa bows deeply, asking for
a light as her stepsisters had instructed.
The Baba Yaga says she will give Vasilisa
her light if she first does some work for
her—or she will eat her.
She gives Vasilisa a series of challenges:
prepare a feast for 12, clean the courtyard
and house, prepare wheat, wash linen, and
sweep.
Vasilisa feeds her doll and it does everything
but prepare the feast.
Baba Yaga is surprised that someone can do
the tasks, and do them well.
Satisfied that the girl has fulfilled her
side of the bargain, she sends the girl home
with one of the skulls with blazing eyes.
Vasilisa returns to her stepmother and stepsisters
bearing the skull like a candle, and they
gratefully receive her having been without
fire for days.
But flames shoot from the skull’s eyes and
burn them to cinders.
All except Vasilisa of course, who ends up
weaving linen so fine she catches the eye
of the Tsar, eventually becoming his bride.
So Baba Yaga does have a heart, but you have
to earn it.
The story demonstrates Baba Yaga’s power
over Morning, Day, and Night—the three horsemen
Vasilisa had seen and whom the Baba Yaga commands.
It also gives us an idea of what purpose the
Baba Yaga tales might serve.
You could argue that the experience teaches
the female audience how to be a wife—to
cook, clean, and sew at another person’s
command.
Not all of the Baba Yaga stories end in marriage,
but they all show an encounter with the old
woman as an initiation from childhood into
adult life.
Her tests and tasks for the protagonists assess
their cleverness and worthiness as adults.
She plays a cultural role as domestic instructor,
demonstrating to young women and men what
moving to a new household is like, and what
tasks they need to master to become eligible
husbands and wives.
Here’s where we can further examine the
origins of the name Baba Yaga.
Her name might even hint at her possible origins
as a deity.
While there are variations, the word ‘baba’
originally referred to a married peasant woman
of childbearing age or older, and in Old Russian
it was used for midwives, sorceresses, and
fortune-tellers.
In modern usage, baba is a derogatory term
designating a difficult old woman, which could
be connected to the image of the Baba Yaga.
In a few indigenous Eastern European languages,
“baba’ is also the name for “pelican.”
Maybe that explains the Baba Yaga’s long,
beaklike nose and her hut’s chicken legs.
‘Yaga’ is harder to pin down, and there
isn’t a scholarly consensus on the word’s
etymology.
Some say it meant “horrible” or “horrifying”
at one point, while others connect it to the
Russian verb meaning “to ride.”
Or we may find it’s origins in the early
Latin for ‘snake’ [anguis).
But ‘Yaga’ is most commonly interpreted
as “bába-witch,” “old granny witch”
or “evil baba.”
If we look at the variants of her name that
use ‘iaga,’ there are more theories including
association with words for disease, illness
(jeza/jedza), horror (jeza), or rage (iagat).
That said, many names for ancient Slavic deities
have been lost over time, and this may be
the case for Baba Yaga.
Perhaps the moniker is a substitute for her
original name that was once so sacred or feared
(likely both) that it could not be said aloud
and is now lost to history.
Attempts to explain Baba Yaga in the 18th
century actually make this association with
ancient Slavic deities as well, including
early indications that she was a pagan goddess
After all, she is associated with supernatural
powers and magical gifts and has power over
life and death…Godlike traits, no?
Except for that whole chicken footed hut deal.
But there might be a more rational explanation
for the appearance of Baba Yaga’s house.
Nomadic hunters in Siberia built storehouses
on top of tree stumps to deter animal foraging.
Structures like the Swedish Sami storehouse
and British saddle stones are similar in form
and function, and may explain why Baba Yaga’s
hut was on “chicken legs.”
And, as I always want to know, what was the
most common burial practice in Neolithic Central
Europe?
Bodies were placed on wooden platforms raised
up on poles so the corpses could dry out and
the bones preserved—which calls to mind
depictions of Baba Yaga’s hut as well.
That certainly associates her with death,
as do all those bones surrounding her home,
and well—the threatening to eat people.
The mortar and pestle that Baba Yaga uses
to get around?
They were essential tools for the everyday
tasks women were in charge of in Slavic culture,
like preparing food and grain, and making
medicine.
A lot of folklorists argue that they have
a sexual symbolism as well, but I’ll let
you Google that.
In modern depictions, Baba Yaga began to serve
as a tool for Socialist propaganda.
The heroes and heroines in these Baba Yaga
tales carryover from the folklore because
of problem solving, hard work, and courage
they exhibit.
These were also traits the former Soviet Union
desired its citizens to have and Baba Yaga
was a popular character on film and television.
But Baba Yaga found global recognition after
the fall of the Soviet Union in 1991, when
media produced there could be reached by other
parts of the world.
And since then, the Baba Yaga appeared in
the Hellboy comics and movies, television
shows like Lost Girl, The Magicians, Supernatural,
and—Arthur?
She’s even in Fortnite.
Mother, bone-breaker, helper, goddess, witch—Baba
Yaga is all of these things.
Telling stories was an essential part of life
for the East Slavic and Russian peoples, whose
folklore was popular in all social classes;
it was customary to tell skazka—folktales—at
feasts and weddings, as well as share them
during times of work or rest at home.
And Baba Yaga was, and still is, one of the
most popular characters.
As grandmotherly advisor or cannibalistic
witch, pagan earth goddess Baba Yaga is a
paradox, which might be why she’s so fascinating—and
even beloved.
I’m going to quote Andreas Johns, who wrote
this incredibly thorough book
on Baba Yaga: “It is clear that there can
be no single correct interpretation or understanding
of Baba Yaga.”
And there’s actually a great freedom in
that.
Both for us as we conjure whichever version
of Baba Yaga that suits us best, and for the
legendary woman and her own powerful potential.